for this lecture I prepared the game or
one of the Kasparov games and he won't
this game very very nice game he won in
just 10 moves and I will go with this
game first and then we're going to do
some tactical ideas and we'll do a
little bit of end games as well okay so
Kasparov is playing white so he played
efore c5 first of all what is the name
of this opening when you see efore c5
yes this is called the opening is
Sicilian defense right most of the time
when black responds it's a defense so
here it's a Sicilian defense Knight f3
Knight f6 this is already a little bit
of a dubious move Knight f6 because
usually the best move here is to play d6
or to play a six here for example ninth
c6 these are the the common moves here
but ninety six is already questionable
questionable move because white can play
just a 5 immediately also but he played
93 first and now he played a six d4
Kasparov did not want to get you know
involved with the e5 so you just played
the classical in 93 d4 so now capture 90
x d4 now B should be for developing the
bishop and after Bishop before what is
black threatening here do you see why he
plays Bishop before because now he has a
threat yes absolute pin yes yes and what
is the threat
yeah I mean he's he's pinning the night
but there is a concrete threat here very
concrete right here he's trying actually
to win something a material yes
which one absolutely he is threatening
to win a pot only for because of the
peon the absolute pin here right because
the pin is the piece is absolutely
pinned and Knight takes e4 will win the
pond so that's why he played this move
Bishop before creating a thread now
instead of trying to defend Kasparov
played he 5 immediately attacking the
knight since he has an opportunity to do
that so he decided to push now 9 d5
plate and now black is putting pressure
on c3 because now he's got two pieces on
it he's pulling pressure so that's why
white needs to do something to stop that
because otherwise he'll just take on c3
so let's say if you just make a random
move he takes and check and look at a
big problem here we lose a rook so if
you don't want to go here you lose a
knight so you lose lots of material and
you lose the game here so you have to do
something remember every part every time
opponent makes a move you have to see
what is he trying to do what is the
threat okay
so and here we see the thread the thread
is to take on c3 okay now what would be
the best way to protect against this
threat
that's an interesting idea you could
play in pound 283 but what if it still
takes tour see the thing is he can still
take this and attack your queen so
that's why we don't want to do that yet
what else is there any other idea we can
do here can we try to develop a piece
here and try to protect against the
threat can we develop it yes absolutely
that's what he played Bishop d2 play
back a spot off and now he blocked the
pin and actually he's threatening now to
take the knight Knight takes c3 and now
he decided to play pawn takes because
it's very important the temples in the
opening if you take back with the bishop
you're not gaining the temple because
you take with the bishop no problem he
will take check and in fact after you
have all this week pawns here and he can
just castle for example so he is fine
here so that's why you want to play pawn
takes because you gain a tempo tempo is
when you attack something and he needs
to move in the opening it's very
important to gain tempos
okay so you take and you attack now now
Bishop f8 played by his opponent his
opponent last name is vest and Bishop
went back to f8 I think he was afraid of
the move Queen g4 if he head down
something like Bishop c5 then Queen g4
is very strong attacking here so that's
why it's it's a problem so he decided to
go back but again it's a passive passive
Square to go to now which piece now you
want to develop here shoe because you
want to make sure you have your pieces
developed right so you can castle so
what piece where
you can go e to or you can go to a
little bit more active square be three
correct
we should be three you can go to D three
or you can go Bishop e2 so you played
Bishop d3 it's very natural when you're
trying to attack you want to have your
bishops lined up like this and then you
can also get your queen in look at this
diagonals now the bishops are
controlling everything and the queen is
coming in so this could be very
dangerous so he played d6 block is in
big trouble but the question is who can
tell me here
why is blocking big trouble here what is
the main reason that he's in big trouble
here think about it if you look
carefully in a position you will see the
reason why he is in big trouble
yes Oh check yeah you could do that but
my question was not really a concrete
move I just want you to tell me like an
I reason why black is it much worse here
why his position is bad here I don't
want you to give me a concrete line just
just tell me the reason why black is in
trouble yes but if you take this pawn
bishop takes now you don't want to lose
your knight
so what is the idea why yes bishops are
blocked in very good that's a very good
point but what else there is something
else you can mention here yes in the
back he is doesn't have that many
squares to go to but something else
there is something else yes
very good look at the development now
look at this how many pieces you see
develop for white 3 how many pieces you
see for black now I think it's very
clear now if you look at that way you
know why why it is so much better here
because of the development remember
developing is the most important thing
in the opening it's not about that I
have double pawns
yes I have double plants but that's not
so important here the important is the
lead in development that white heads
here and you'll see why he managed to
win this game very quickly so now
casparo played Queen e2 and now for a
moment he has developed 4 pieces 3 minor
pieces and his Queen and black didn't
develop any of his pieces yet and now
his opponent blundered he was probably
under so much pressure here that he just
blundered and lost the game immediately
he played good night
d7 and now let's I want you to spend
about a couple of minutes I don't want
you to raise your hands so don't I don't
want you to raise your hand now for 2
minutes I want you to think and try to
come up with a winning combination that
Kasparov did 97 was a blunder because
something was protected but anyway I he
putting it there it's no longer
protecting and now a very nice
combination will win the game here for
white
don't rush calculate for two minutes
calculate try to see the idea here
you
okay if you ready raise your hand if you
see the combination here okay yes and if
I take okay don't wash yet it's it's not
so simple yes yeah well that's just a
move but again it's not really creating
okay let me give you a hint you need to
sacrifice something sacrifice here okay
you need to do a sacrifice here to open
the position of the king so the king is
weak and then it's exposed and then you
can try to take advantage of it and
organize a mating attack here but you
have to see couple of moves not just the
one move yes excellent very good that's
what he did nine ticks is six double
exclamation mark brilliant move
let's see why so he has to take in fact
in the game he didn't take and last next
move here to resign by the way it was a
very nice move by Kasparov again to
force the resignation but let's see why
he cannot take first thing he takes now
I'm up a piece continue very good check
now he's blocking it
did you see this one now it looks like
he blocked it for a moment
check correct
he takes Queen takes what look see we
have a choice here
tricky woman here we have a choice we
take the rook valued five pounds or we
take the pawn why huh
it's important to say check almost like
a meteor yeah he has to go here only
move and now the key move here is the
key move here look at the King now the
king is weak now what can you do now yes
very good check and the King cannot go
anywhere he has to go here and then we
say check we say check we take his queen
and it's always okay he has to resign
it's just down a queen for no reason
okay so that's the idea why 96 and by
the way who can tell me why King g7 is
losing this is also losing losing the
Queen how
let's see now what can we do here we
have to always look for that check
always look for that check here check is
important yes bishop d 5 g 5 check
correct has to go Knight f6 continue
it's not over yet yes you could do that
but look at the pawn pawn or a bishop
pawn it's Knight yes now he takes back
correct if it moves the King you take
your screen now he takes here and now
what is the tactic here let's see if you
got the tactic here it's right there now
the this idea is called skewer you know
the pins and forks these are more common
so this is skewer idea okay you skewered
the King and you win his Queen here yes
excellency the skewers it's not like
it's a pin or a four gets skewered check
King moves anywhere and we take the
Queen and the game is over
alright very very nice idea so this
doesn't work I want everyone to pay
attention because we're going to review
after we finish and I want to see if you
remember all the moves now his opponent
went king - Queen to b6 he realized if
he takes the knight he's going to get
mated or lose his queen at least he
plays Queen b6 and now who can find
Kasparov moves because parrots move here
that will force the resignation because
otherwise White will be upper rook and
upon for no reason here
what is the move here huh the idea
involved here is called discovery check
you make a move and you setup a
discovery check can you do that you make
a move and then there is a discovery
make a move and if he takes it next one
with this cavity check yes correct
very good check that's a fork right he
has to take no choice he can do anything
so if it takes what do you do now you
got you go up to 9 you got to see it now
you give up tonight you've got to have
the follow-up you've got to and now
discovery check yes d6 that's 6 check
you see that idea discovery check King
has to move and you take and you win the
game that's why he resigned very
effective win actually this was played
in looks like in all Olympiad in 1977
very effective win by Kasparov after 97
his opponent resigned because he was
going to lose the rook at least and if
he takes even worse losing the Queen
okay okay now we're going to do a couple
of tactical positions okay so if you
look at the position I mean block is up
exchange when you're up exchange it
means you have a look for a minor piece
that term when I say up a exchange means
you have a rook versus a minor piece
minor piece value is three rook is five
so basically up a exchange means you're
up to puns okay but sometimes it's not
so clear you could be up a exchange like
here you're up exchanging in fact you're
plus up three pounds because black has
four pounds why it is only one so you
have a exchange plus three pounds but
you're not going to be able to win this
in fact you're going to be checkmated it
removes white checkmate in three moves
because if you don't checkmate you're
going to lose white to play checkmate in
three well think about it it's not so
simple checkmate in three in a positions
like this when you down so much material
and here's a lot of pieces the idea
needs to be a check yes
yeah but do you see the threat he wants
to take your Quinn so you don't have
time to play any slow moves okay no time
for slow moves you make a slow move
could be a trouble okay no time for the
slow move here it's got to be a check
check check mate
check check check mate remember that two
checks and third one you say check mate
yes correct ninety-seven check now
forcing the opponent King to go back to
h8 only move right he's got no choice
does he have a choice here no choice he
goes to the corner now and now you have
the King what do you want it to be now
but it looks so safe you know all these
pawns are shielding the King how you
going to try to checkmate here it looks
like it's completely safe here but
you're going to come up with a brilliant
idea to open the king so you can
checkmate here so let's see what can you
do here yes in the back okay yes
do you see the checkmater because you
can only sacrifice your queen if you
ever made so you see it queen h7
brilliant idea sacrificing the queen he
has to take and now what is the move
check make because look at the night is
doing an awesome job guarding those two
crucial squares and it's a checkmate
very nice very nice idea remember not
all this if you down a material you're
going to lose don't assume you're going
to lose okay you can still win if you
have enough resources to come up with
some tactical ideas got it
excellent okay very good
now I like to do a very famous game
combination here okay this is played by
Capablanca this this game and he came
out with a very nice tactic to win a
piece
and if black doesn't want to win the PC
is going to get checkmate
it doesn't want to lose a piece he's
going to get checkmated so let's see
this idea here white to play and win a
minor piece or checkmate if you place
the wrong move here now we really want
to make him here but we can't really do
that because the bishop is there huh
well the bishop is protecting see
otherwise you were thinking mate but
that's not a mate because I actually
take as a win the piece
now what is the idea here it's very nice
it's a combination though it's a form of
combination you need to calculate here
so what can we do here and that Bishop
is such a big important piece here that
is protecting can we try to do something
to that bishop it's a very nice idea yes
it's protected remember that would have
been too simple you take my piece there
yeah then you win it's it's a nice idea
very important move it this is difficult
one compared to the previous one so we
did this is much more difficult now and
play by a world-champion Capablanca yes
if I take you
so be careful yeah you can't just give
up a piece we got to have a follow up
here yes here Todd we'll take your queen
you know your queen is hanging first of
all the problem is the queen is hanging
all the most valuable piece is hanging
here okay so remember that's the problem
because we can't just lose it unless we
have a mate or something something
really strong here do you see a check
here do you see a check mate maybe check
will help you to get out of this maybe
check I always look for check check
captures check you have to look for
those so yeah when you travel so so we
have a check here okay let's see in the
back yeah yeah but the bishop is
gardening it you lose the Quinn so now
would be a mate actually but the bishop
is guarding it so we need to check yes
but look at the Quinn can the Quinn take
you sideways haha that helps how does
that help okay you're closer it's only
one more check left we did the other two
we did the others - no guys only one
left now one check left yeah
correct check he cannot take this
because of this pin so he can only go
here no choice he can only go there okay
now
now what can we do here now the idea
here it's over workpiece here and the
Queen here on c7 is the overworked piece
okay because it's protecting f7 and
protecting the bishop so can we try to
deflect it can we try to deflect this
Queen from here can we do that well
that's the deflection but not the
strongest one you have something better
here yes that's an idea but the problem
is he takes so think about it sacrifice
here you have a sacrifice here to
deflect you use the oftentimes sacrifice
is the best way to deflect it it often
times the sacrifice is the best way to
deflect it it
yes yes rook takes d8 yeah my rook takes
your da my route can take care all right
let's try to see now what about this
Queen can we use the screen now what if
we do this what if we sacrifice our
queen do you see the idea now so he
takes right deflection is accomplished
he is no longer protecting this really
well right he's no longer protecting f7
now well Lucas but what else the rook is
doing here protecting the king the back
rank now first the Queen was overworked
now the rook is overworked
because he's protecting the back rank
and is also protecting the pawn and now
you can take advantage of the overworked
piece here by a very nice tactic yesh
very nice tactic in the back close very
close but the problem is he will say
checkmate ok but think about it to try
to work it work around it work around it
yes absolutely correct check now check
for cry if he goes away what do we do
take the Queen and we wrap a piece
remember I said when a piece or make so
of course this is completely lost he's
not going to do this so he has to take
and if it takes checkmate in three
you see it now look at the King we
deflected them now what are we going to
do - checkmate check I don't say
checkmate because you can prolong it by
putting a queen here but that doesn't
change anything it just delays it
nothing more check checkmate
do you see how that works again play by
a world champion this is a very nice and
advanced level combination here okay but
we wanted to do advanced things here so
learn from the champions very good
excellent let's move forward now and
games remember I mentioned we can do
some end games so here we go
endgame position for you very nice way
to win by using an idea called
deflection deflection is when you
sacrifice a piece to move the king or a
piece from a square that is doing a good
job okay so here which piece we would
like to deflect white to play and win
there is only one way to win it and if
you need to find the right move fish
Oh think about it a little bit think
about it try to double-check if you have
an answer we have a passed pawn our goal
is to promote this pawn but it's not so
easy
it's not so easy
white to play and win okay everyone
focus
yes but okay five he takes C and then it
takes your pawn
the idea is to sacrifice the roof but we
want to sacrifice it to a different
square that we deflect one of the
crucial defenders which piece we can try
to deflect it to be able to promote our
pawn into a queen we want to promote
that pawn into a queen but we need to
deflect his piece which pieces which
piece I'm referring to yes that's the
piece I'm referring to yes but how
question is we find that out now but how
can we deflect the matter yes
excellent excellent move this is a
brilliant idea of sacrificing the rook
let's try to see why this is such a
strong idea he takes and now rook is no
longer on the file to protect the pawn
right so what do you do passed pawns
meant to be pushed and we push and we
are ready to Quinn now the problem for
him he cannot go here we take he cannot
move the King we take so he goes check
and now what do you do you have to go to
the right square here you go to the
wrong store you can even lose here you
go to the rocks where you can really
spoil the win here the correct square is
that's nice you can also go to be too
but yeah Hindi to works also
and then you promote the pond if you had
gone here you in fact lose because he
checks and his route gets behind it and
wins the pond if you had gone yeah you
really have to if you'd gone here it's
also now draw check attacks your rook
you go here if he promotes you promote
he takes so you take his rook he takes
your pawn draw but that's not going to
happen because we're not going to make a
mistake we're going to go king d2 and
the game is over weak win now but there
is one more variation you need to tell
me what's happening if I play rook to be
four what if I go rook before now what
do you do now remember very you don't
have you have to play precisely
now
we have the past pound so what we should
do now yes push so he cannot just go
away because you take the rook so he has
to go here king c5 because this way now
he is protecting it and he is attacking
it he is protecting it and attacking it
and if this has happened very important
move you have here that will help you to
move his king so you can win that rook
and the game here and the move is
correct because if it blocks it then we
can exchange and do what promote into a
queen and if it goes away what do we do
promote he'll take you don't promote yet
what do you do first take the piece
right and now the king is in a corner
let's see how quickly we can checkmate
here first thing we need to do is cut
can we cut the King here so he doesn't
escape anywhere what's the cut here
excellent yes now he goes here waiting
move needed here okay waiting what we
wait now he goes to the side we check he
goes back we come up he goes to the side
we check he goes here let's say he goes
here let's say he's trying to play a
better defense so you come up and now
you need a waiting move your two moves
away from checkmate in here two moves
away from the mate what do you do now
waiting move waiting move you want to
wait until this King goes to the corner
and it's
anywhere here will do it okay anywhere
but only here is not here he'll take you
here look to c6 you said cannot go here
cannot go here has to go to the corner
and as soon as the king is in a corner
checkmate
excellent very good all right so that's
the idea excellent okay good job
everyone
today and you did really well and we're
looking forward see you next week
you